just uh because I could I couldn't tell
you right now what I said after that
fight that was all almost straight from
here yeah dude like I couldn't tell you
all I remember saying UFC apparently
yeah
I'm like what the [ __ ] just happened I
missed out on two sponsors apparently
because I didn't say what yeah what I
was supposed to say to bring up their
name it's like bro it's really good
sorry I just got pushed in my head 13
times you want me to remember him uh
thinking of it now I can't think of it
but uh but yeah dude like there's
there's a deeper passion now like to get
the
the notes and stuff actually like this
morning just going through Instagram hey
man I just want to let you know you
always have a house here in Scotland I
didn't know what I wanted to do with
myself I saw you you just made me smile
yeah I made it through my day and I was
like yeah it's dope you right there man
right there I'm never coming soon
I'm actually never gonna be in Scotland
but never gonna meet you back